jpeg PNG webp GIF and SVG what's the
difference between these image formats
let's simplify the equation by
separating the raster formats from the
vector formats a raster or bitmap is
like a grid of pixels best suited for
complex pictures like the ones you take
on your camera but they require lots of
memory at high resolution and lose their
Clarity when scaled up JPEG and PNG are
the ogs from the 90s jpeg is smaller
because it doesn't support transparency
and uses lossy compression while PNG has
transparency with lossless compression
GIF not GIF is similar but can also
combine frames to make animations webp
is a new format from Google that has the
best of all worlds with smaller
transparent animatable images on the
other side we have vector image formats
that are good for flat Graphics like
logos and icons because they use
geometry and code to represent the image
which means it can be scaled to any size
without losing resolution hence the name
scalable vector graphics